all right tobin auto group the sponsors
of this next segment is helping to make
our great toy drive even greater rocky
stop by one of their dealerships to
learn more
we are so excited to be partnering with
tobin auto group for our great toy drive
during the holiday season we're here
with hyrum here in your brand new
location the valley auto mall for the
alpha and fiat dealership so speaking of
toys let's get to the big toys first
okay what do you guys have here hey so
at the tobin alpha romeo fiat dealership
we have the the brand new um alfa
romeo's that they just got redesigned
and then we also have the the fiat brand
which is a great brand's been around for
a long time and right now we're offering
zero percent up to 72 months so nice so
gifting the adults the most importantly
gifting the kids in our community who
need it the most so let's talk about the
great toy drive what are we doing
so we're just gathering toys where we're
gathering any unopened um brand new toys
for every toy that you guys donate
top's gonna match it so one for one
we're gonna double up the toys we're
excited for that oh my gosh and chop if
you don't know he's the owner here so
he's the reason why we're doing this
such such a great cause here um you guys
are partnering also with the shade tree
why choosing that organization so if you
guys don't know what shade tree is it's
an organization that helps battered
women and battered kids so we we're so
grateful to be able to give back and
bring joy to those kids absolutely so
bringing joy to the adults who are ready
for a nice car and also bringing joy to
the kids who need it the most how can
people help um this we we have three
locations where you guys could donate we
have tobin uh kia tobin alfa romeo fiat
and then we have our tobin dodge store
so if you guys want to come down bring a
couple toys for the kids we're gonna
match it yeah let's fill these boxes
with your brand new unwrapped toys for
the kids in our community who need it
the most so thank you to channel eight
the shade tree and the tobin auto group
for spread enjoy this holiday season
thank you rob appreciate your time
we're hoping you'll help us make the
holidays brighter for local families
we're hosting a great toy drive through
december 15th with the tobin auto group
if you want to participate drop off a
new unwrapped toy or gift card at any of
the dealerships on your screen all of
the donations will benefit the shade
tree